Привет! Это второй модуль программы AI Native Designer. Модуль называется System Architect,
то есть архитектор системы. Давай быстро сверим, где мы на карте программы. В первом модуле мы
собирали данные, рекурсивный брифинг, исследования, персоны, тесты, PRD. У нас на руках документ,
в котором зафиксировано, что делать, для кого и почему. Второй модуль — это про то,
как из этого PRD теперь собрать ту самую систему продуктов в Figma. Информационная архитектура,
вайрфреймы, дизайн-системы, UI-кит, финальные экраны — всё, что должно лежать в файле перед тем,
как мы начнём наполнять это уже в визуал. То есть в третьем модуле мы наполним систему визуалом,
через модели, промпты, ноды. В четвёртом превратим её уже в живой продукт, код deploy-агенты. И у нас
получится такой полноценный продукт из того, с чего мы начинали в прошлом модуле. То есть программа
идёт по хронологии дизайн-процесса. Сначала данные, потом структура, потом визуал, потом live. Пара слов о том,
как устроена работа в этом модуле. Я буду вести сквозное демо на одном большом проекте,
сервис облачного хранилища — тот, который я разбирал в предыдущем модуле. Соберём полноценную
архитектуру, дизайн-систему, много экранов и так далее. У нас в домашках — это то, на чём я буду
демонстрировать вам процесс. У вас же в домашках будут маленькие микрозадания, которые я буду давать
под каждым уроком. Они скромнее того, что я делаю в демо, и это сделано намеренно. В модуле у нас есть
разные инструменты, разные фреймворки. Большие проекты быстро съедают токены. И сначала нам нужно поставить
механики. Чтобы вы не тратили кучу токенов и времени, ознакомились конкретно с механиками, сделали это быстро,
экстра удобно и понятно. В домашках будут микрозадания. А полноценную сборку уже своего проекта мы делаем в курсовом
задании, в 12-м уроке. Там вы возьмёте свой продукт из первого модуля, то есть либо свой продукт, либо тот, который я вам в
табличке выдал, и уже проходите всё то, что мы в этом модуле изучили. Теперь немного о самом главном инструменте модуля — это
Figma MCP. Это мост между Figma и E-агентом. В качестве агента мы будем использовать CloudCode. Он лучше всех с этим справляется.
пишем ему команду — собери там фрейм какой-нибудь, исследуй мою дизайн-систему, пересобери её и так далее. Он всё это
прекрасно делает. И на данный момент справляется с этим лучше любого другого инструмента. На самом деле, я думаю,
это вообще не скоро изменится. Поэтому очень важно понимать, как он работает, как его подключить. Мы будем
делать это в следующем уроке. Также отдельно я упомяну Google Stitch — это бесплатный AI-генератор вайфреймов из
текста или скетча. Это будет такой вспомогательный инструмент. Ну и в целом, по ходу этого
модуля мы будем рассматривать альтернативы, которые выполняют те же действия, но, возможно,
под какие-то другие задачи или на другом уровне. В общем, сформируем полную картину того,
что и зачем нам использовать. Итак, давайте кратко, что нас ждёт в модуле, на какие темы он вообще
разбит. Сначала мы подключаем Figma MCP — это технический сетап. Потом мы собираем архитектуру продукта,
информационную архитектуру, сайтмэп, юзерфлоу. Через MCP на Figma Canvas это делаем за минуты. Дальше
рассматриваем, как это может работать в уже готовом проекте. То есть, если у вас уже есть несколько компонентов,
но полноценную дизайн-система это не собирает, или у вас грязный макет, который нужно привести в порядок,
смотрим, как применить тот же подход в таком случае. Потом работаем с дизайн-системой также через ИИ. Это токены,
адаптация готовой библиотеки под наш бренд, сборка UI-китая — всё через MCP. Ну и в конечном итоге сборка
проекта. Варфрейм и финальные экраны. В финале будет большое курсовое задание, свой проект из первого
модуля или тот крупный кейс, который я вам давал через табличку. На выходе у вас будет полноценный
Figma проект, сайтмэп, юзерфлоу, дизайн-система с токенами, типографикой и палитрой, UI-кит из каких-то
самых главных базовых компонентов. Его можно расширять по собственному желанию. Ну и от 3 до 5 финальных
экранов. Конечно, зависит от того, что было у вас в задании. Если там какой-то Landos, то не обязательно делать
несколько экранов. Но мы ещё об этом поговорим. Это будет чистый файл, по сути, готовые макеты,
которые в дальнейшем можно наполнять визуалом. Этим мы и займёмся уже в следующем модуле.
Последнее и самое важное — для этого модуля нам обязательно нужна подписка на CloudCode. Без неё MCP
не будет нормально работать. Есть ещё, конечно, аналоги, такие как, например, Codex, но там значительно
хуже всё это работает. Модели GPT слабее. В общем, не нужно в это углубляться. CloudCode — отличная вещь,
нужно её взять. Ссылка на то, где её купить, будет в описании под этим уроком. Там же вся
дополнительная информация. Обязательно её читайте, прежде чем тратить свои деньги на подписки. А в
следующем уроке мы подключим Figma MCP CloudCode. Это первый технический урок модуля. Ставим инструменты,
настраиваем агента, смотрим, как это работает, какие есть возможности. В общем, всю базу технички мы
закрываем. Кроме подписки ничего к нему готовить не нужно. Увидимся в нём. Готовьте
свои Cloud Подписки и до встречи в следующем уроке.